hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to dark cut this is game
that came out a while ago in flash made
by Jam tbo to who's one of my favorite
game developers especially in the flash
Newgrounds era if you think this game
think medieval times meets surgeon
simulator even though this came out way
before surgeon simulator ever did
you're just you're a doctor ok I'll let
the I'll let the game explain itself
dear most humble scholar with haste
please remove the arrow from Captain
Harold's right leg
we need upon the battlefield by tomorrow
morning chop-chop please hurry and
remember we want the least amount of
pain possible regards the Royal Guard
the douchebags now I've played this one
before and I say this one because
there's two more games that I have not
played but I kind of wanted to show you
guys like what it's all about because
it's kind of ridiculous and kind of
brutal and kind of horrible and also
it's really fun so I can't can't really
complain even when spatters the blood
are going all over the screen and I have
to extract all this [ __ ] out of
people's bodies replant some human
tissue
oh good enough passed why not I did
great in my own humble opinion I'm
fantastic
ok dear most humble scholar please
remove these weird boils from this
individual we have a feeling it is some
kind of new disease not sure not experts
on the subject so usually means
necessary to cleanse remove and
eliminate the problem regards the
douchebags known as the Royal Guard now
this is where the game starts to get a
little bit gross because it's it's a
scrub the bubonic plague boils oh let me
just let me just get my hands all in
nurse if you wouldn't mind please hand
me the the vinegar and the rose water if
you wouldn't mind I couldn't remember
what it was it's been a while from die
play this game everybody split open the
first boil
oh god that was spattered yeah I should
probably put a warning at the beginning
of this game but for some reason like
this was suggested after I played the
visitor because it's kind of a little in
the same era of games it's got that
morbid curiosity factor like you don't
want to see this stuff
you really don't really I don't yeah but
I mean you have to extract pus it's it's
not exactly the most pleasant of games
but it's got the veins to clip
passageways what why is this how they
did it back then I'm not exactly sure
it's been a long time since I played
this one I don't remember this Reese
tits the skin by criss cross you know I
wouldn't need to do that if I didn't cut
up in this my opinion what do I know
yes you're giving me bad direction here
you know I mean this is before I learned
to tell you to shut up okay so that's
good Oh scrub the entire why not just go
all wishy-washy with everything well you
know what they say once you wish upon a
star you'll scrub all those boils away
and that sure that's what they said
anyway I did great I think dear most
humble scholar upon thine discretion we
have brought the vampire to your elbow
day so you may take care of ready in the
correct fashion please take care of this
problem immediately
one false move will most likely beat
your death regards the Royal nurse where
do you get these cases from I remember
this at all good all right god damn why
do I have to do this ever get bike rusev
oh oh oh you're gonna make me time this
eh Oh aim what do I got a press space oh
good
oh god I gotta click this time okay I
don't really know what to do now oh
implant garlic into the wound of course
because this is the proper way to kill a
vampire actually I wouldn't be surprised
if this is like the original document oh
he's probably gonna kill me after this I
wouldn't be surprised if this is
actually the documented way that you're
supposed to get rid of a hey what am I
gonna kiss him oh I'm gonna mark the axe
line oh that's much less good than
kissing him oh no bunch of bull what a
piece of [ __ ] ah god damn it okay I'll
be back
you're right back okay here we go here
we go again I can't mess this one up
again oh man pink pink it's like playing
one of those timing games in an arcade
why do I need to do this [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh come on to be stuck on that forever
oh dear most humble scholar say you made
it this far we were expecting much less
from you thank you douche bags in fact
we were expecting nothing Oh glorious
douche bags you're welcome at that
congratulations you have done well I
appreciate it regards the Royal two's
bags so anyway that was it
but there is dark cut two and three
which I've never played before and they
have a lot more work put into him at
least I think JMT bo2 has made some
really incredible games in the past like
this is the only level achievement
unlocked something like you like that
he's made a lot of those types of games
and you've probably played one of his
games in the past he's phenomenal go
look him up if you haven't played him
already he nags great stuff so thank you
all
someone for watching let me know if you
want to see dark cut two and three if
you're weird like that in the
description below or in the comments
below and as always I will see you in
the next